In last week's VFX artists react video we talked about the muzzle flashes in John wick and how they're not an accurate
Representation of real muzzle flashes they serve the purpose of the movie, but I think we can improve them
I think we can make them better. So that's one of the things we do here at corridor fake guns
Now this is not going to be quite as crazy of a change as a Scorpion King instead of we're going to see as us
Taking an artistry in craft that we have spent years honing
We're gonna try to make them more accurate to real-life muzzle flashes would be an improvement. Would it be unnoticeable?
What does matter in the world of action and what subtle things can make a difference you will see?
Some scenes for John wick with the gun effects completely redone by us and you let us know if you think it's an improvement
It's time to get to work
Are you thinking John wick a lot John wick dude me too? I love it an amazing choreography those gun effects
I just I don't think they look all that great. Here's the first house
The most important thing is the burst of light and they're getting that the exposure of the muzzle flashes feels off
Like I feel like they need to be more blown out. They're shooting in almost complete darkness. Yeah. I mean the gun handling is great
We do a lot of action videos here at corridor, especially with guns you've been doing gun videos for a long time
We've hardened real guns for various videos. We've done blank firing guns for various videos
We've done a lot of CG muzzle flashes because when you're on set both real guns and blank firing guns
Tend not to be too practical
the thing is if blank firing guns are actually dangerous because you're still
Ejecting a ton of force from the front of the pistol
Now we talked about this in our visual effects artist react ever
So that went up last week, but when you're in this close quarters
You can't use a blank firing gun because it can actually hurt and kill the person in front you with just that muzzle explosion
So if we leave close quarter combat scenes, they're using barrel plug blank guns functionally, very similar to a gas blowback airsoft gun
And they're adding the effects afterwards of the gunshots. Thanks to our experience doing it. For real
We know what it should look like. So let's break it down friend by frame for a second here
We have a muzzle flash and we have some fake lighting being added to the scene, you know
They're kind of lightening up the people around it
but the fake lighting is only right here and the side of this guy's not getting hit with light the background here is not really
Getting it with light. There's no shadow of like John wick on the background and in the second frame
There's just a weird half transparent muzzle flash. That's not what happens in real life when you film blank firing guns
You shouldn't have a big puff of fire with another half transparent smaller puff of fire as if the guns
Inhaling the muzzle flash back into it
this is like one of the most common errors of muzzle flashes is having it stick to the gun like
It came out here the guns moving but the air the expanding gasses that are the muzzle flash
Are there in front and that they're not parented with the gun. They would stay where they were initially
I mean, we don't know that he's not firing a fully auto pistol
Right on two shots off
There's also no smoke coming out of this guns
and it's one of the things that really sells the power of the gun that shows you those expanding gases those forces that are
injecting that little piece of metal out of the gun because in real life if you shoot a pistol
Within a third of a second just smoke for the muzzle flash
will have you ejected out about six feet the smoke from a muzzle flash is what gives a gun it's powered by not having the
Smoke in these scenes with John wick they're missing a huge portrait of what could really make these muzzle flashes hit hard
actually the thing that bugs me when I watch this scene is
The sound design to be honest if you listen to it, you hear the Zips and zaps your lips
That actually sounds closer to what an airsoft pistol sounds like yeah than a real gun
So that's literally just the sound of the mechanical elements because then when you're listening to in the scene you can just
Hear that happening. No gunshots. I'm gonna go back a few frames
Let's just make sure we know Gunny's using and that looks like an HK something with an extended
compensator awesome
Okay, so it's not a suppressor
It shouldn't be going pew I want to feel the effect of the sound of these guns filling every corner of the room
Let's do a quick demonstration
So pay attention not to the initial bang because that lasts for a friend pay attention to the tail this time
Everyone just shuts up explodes. You'll hear it
Tail is a lot shorter, but it's got that boom eNOS. So it's hard to describe what the Frick is booming
It's like it's like imagine of marshmallow
exploding really hard
Yeah
All right, so let's see we can make John wick even better
Let's see if we can fix the molar flashes and try something in the sound design to really make these guns feel powerful
So I'm gonna do is I'm gonna start with a couple scenes that we erase the second muzzle flash that's there for a second frame
And put our Mosel flash elements in there. I'm going to try to adjust the lighting. I'm going to add smoke
I'm gonna add counter bloom. What are you gonna do? No, but it's gonna be sick
What I'm thinking is I'm actually going to snag some of these firecrackers
Record them that's gonna make the whole thing way more punch here
It's gonna get a really transform the scene the guns sound different as well as look different. Let's do it
Hey guys, it's John here Jake. How are you?
Hey, since everyone is trying to make the muzzle flash is in my movie a little bit better
I thought I'd come in here and offer everyone a little bit of advice on how today's sponsor Squarespace can make your lives better
How's that sound guys sound good?
Hey guys. John here. What are you working on now?
So you don't have a problem in the future making sure our robot is rigged up in unity
well
Guess what with Squarespace you can make one post on your Squarespace website and that'll post
Automatically on all those profiles like Twitter Facebook and Tumblr also
It's optimized so you don't to worry about the titles not fitting or the number of words you're using not working
Consider that next time you do a presentation
Definitely to get this I consider that I'm John you're working again. I'm always working. I'm retired. How do you know that?
What are you working on? We're fixing your movie. Do you know who's gonna own this video at the end of the day?
Corridor digital well with Squarespace they offer 100%
content ownership meaning that all the stuff that you put onto your Squarespace website you own so will in this video I
Hope so if you decide you don't want to use Squarespace one day they offer one-click portability
Meaning that you get all that information right back to you. What are you working on Sam? Yeah
I'm just working trying to get this robot working in real time and unity for a state grant presentation
How many people are gonna work on this robot with you know one I work a lot?
It would probably really helpful if you worked with other people. That's not true
And so that's what's great about square space square space offers multiple contributors to the same website
Also, you can toggle access meaning that if you don't like that guy over there selim. Hey, guess what?
You can't actually have that permission butBut you can your robot is going through. Thank you. You would if it's gonna work
Yeah, it's great. Now. I'm psyched. Jake's dressed up like John Wayne is coming over here
Hey, what are you working on?
Squarespace offers you traffic oversight on any of your websites meaning that if you need to know who comes to your website
Where they come from scores cuase can tell you that super useful actually less detects it out
so if you're interested in starting your own Squarespace just goes
Just go to squarespace.com slash corridor crew and you get 10% off. Your first purchase is your leg, okay?
that's
I'm working on it. Hold on guys. Okay. Jake's being weird today, baby. Yeah
So like what they're using it's kinda like 80s drums gated reverb the drums cuz they have a normal gun sound effect where it goes
They're cutting it off shorts that goes
They're not using indoor samples they're using like gun on the range sound effects, it's Michael to fix that
So I'm just gonna do a quick little audio pass here to punch it up a bit two things one
Get some custom explosion Foley using some firecrackers and then I'm also gonna dig into my sound packs touch it up a little bit
Here don't be alarmed
Let's do that again, but I
Hope I don't need the the pop so much I I need everything
The thing is is that when it explodes everyone needs to be totally quiet or else it's unusable
No, thanks
Now takes me to my happy place entirely honest like that
Sulfur smell is this like ball rocket fights 4th of July all sorts of shenanigans
Well, Sam's blowing scrap that I'm sitting here working on the effects for this shot. So here's the raw scene
Okay, focus on one muzzle flash here. This one this guy shoots right here all the flashes
Don't just move stuck to the end of the gun. Once they come out the gun. That's where it comes out of
It's like blowing smoke, you know, you can move your mouth the smoke stays where you blew it out not to mention
It's kind of fading out and looking weird in the second frame and muzzle flashes. Only exists for one frame
So the very first thing you have to do is I said erase the second muzzle flash here. We have that
so the next thing I did is I added one of our muzzle flash elements that we filmed ourselves out in the desert from an
Actual pistol so a couple interesting things to point out here
You can see a really bright point where it's coming out of the gun
You can see sparks the sparks continue for a couple of frames that element brings a lot of light
I'm taking this muzzle flash then putting it on top of the other muzzle flash for the very first frame their base muzzle flash isn't
That bad but it's missing some of these details and that's what I'm bringing back in with mine
It also doesn't just stick to the gun arbitrarily that look really weird. So the next thing the most
Important thing in my opinion is the smoke smoke gives the guns their punch back in the day
We were filming sync. We needed some smoke for our muzzle flashes
and so we got an air compressor and some flour and we shot the flour out of an air compressor and then we ramp the
Footage so you get a more acceleration at the beginning and that first come out of the gun
Works so well for showing the power of a there it is boom
The smoke should be about twice the length the muzzle flash
Based on all my studying of actual gun shooting and then should move at a pretty good speed
Alright, so now we have our flash and our smoking there. The last thing I need to do is add some fake lighting
So there's already a little bit of fake lighting in the scene
but it feels a little dark like this the wall behind the guy should be lit up the wall below key on his arm should
Be lit up. I'm going to brighten them myself and when everything is said and done you get something kind of like this
You can see the smoke you can see the sparks looks pretty good and pretty punchy
Kind of Babur awesome some muzzle flashes here for you guys. Happy a little flare. Yeah
This is like one of my biggest pet peeves. I'm happy. I can show you guys how I would do it
I'm just a passionate individual that loves action movies terminator. I watch this every night when I go to sleep
Check out Brian frenzies video t2 muscle spray Brian frenzy played the law and vghs
I'm being completely serious
If anybody from John wick production team sees this video and would like us to do muzzle flashes for your movie
I would love to do that. It would be super cool. Send us an email
And so I'm starting to chop up the original audio track and do some creative fades at which time the gun fires
The sound in the original audio disc. So this is basically what's happening on the original audio track that
Initial like spike. I'm taking them out and replacing them with my own punchy elements these tails here
This is the gun and just for reference
That's where I'm at a little more punchy a little more poppy
Ready to show some the effects here might be effects sir. I'm really nervous about a sound design
We're more professional muzzle flashes than we are professional sound designers. So be nice to me
Okay, so I haven't actually seen any of this. These are these are fresh eyeballs. Seeing your muzzle flashes hear this
Let's get a refresher of the original the original
Jonathan walk
That's pretty deep right back wait, that's actually Keanu
Here's our version these are the improved ones
Sit-outs home. That looks so much better
Everything looks really good. I'm gonna be completely honest. I didn't really notice a difference
I noticed the smoke the smoke made them feel a little less like Video Copilot
Tutorial no friends Andrew. I
Noticed the the nice sparks coming out of the gun - those look really good and just like show you guys some before and after
Like here's the original of John wick Bing
here's that same shot that
Looks so much better. See that's the thing about muzzle flashes in motion
It's really hard to tell the difference, but when you actually pause and look at the flash, it's very clear
The sparks look so good trying some fake shadows under the wall. It really makes it feel like it's an actual lighting
That's there. These are such better muzzle flashes. What muzzle flashes did you guys use? What collection did you use?
These are the pistol side desert muzzle flashes that you filmed out in the desert with Adrian back in the day
Just saying paid off speaking of weak-ass guns. I actually decided to go the other way, so
It's nothing but you guys just buckle your seatbelts hold onto your pants because we're about to get
Don't let me dad some bigwig energy. Let's do it
We don't
An improvement
Mortar round
No joke. No, I feel like once they make like the tents John wick movie is actually going to look like
Cracking the last bullet is like Michelangelo inside the wall. I would he shoots through the wall quote
I was like, I was like to bleep blow up a whole wall
Alright, well, let us know what you guys thought was this an improvement on the original John wick
do you feel like our muzzle flashes are better or do you feel like Peters muzzle flashes were the best muzzle flashes that anybody could
Ever make and that's what the next John wick movie should have inside of them
Also, please leave a comment if there are any other scenes you would like us to take a look at any other movies
Whatever it is, please leave a comment below and don't forget to subscribe
Just in case we do it
For some reason when everyone does their muzzle flashes it's this shape
It's either this or the dreaded like
You know what I'm saying? Like it's it's more it's more this one. It's the most common one. They do it's like this
Way me no, no, I'm not done
What for this shape in the most of the old ones